all right uh yesterday
the green bay packers go down to texas
to take on the dallas cowboys the
packers didn't have devonta adams right
to me
that made it an easy pick cowboys win
this game because we've seen what
happens when the packers have devante
adams they throw him the football they
throw him the football they throw him
the football until the defense commits
extra resources to stop him and then
everybody else is open or yesterday
without devante adams they got it done
unbelievable
aaron jones running game 107 yards
rushing 75 yards receiving four
touchdowns for aaron jones and the
packers moved the ball they got a big
lead they were up 31-3 in the third
quarter and then they had to hold on and
they did hold on to get the victory but
this has to be the most encouraging
offensive performance because they did
it without adams definitely i mean it
really was they got to be encouraged by
a lot of things i mean the fact that
their defense caused some turnovers
their offense capitalized but
it does seem like they're turning the
corner as far as getting this offense
going and getting the run game going i
mean it really it was you got to be so
pleased if you're a packers fan or matt
lefleur about the formula that won the
game yesterday yeah some good solid
defense dallas certainly had some
turnovers you know some of that was
self-inflicted i get that but the
packers did capitalize whether it was
run game and then rogers just making
timely throws and plays like he always
does and all of a sudden you look up and
you go whoa it's 17 nothing and we're
going into halftime and then dallas goes
three and out and rogers and company put
another good to drive together and you
go whoa it's 24 to nothing this game has
gotten away from the dallas cowboys and
of course then they're not able to stay
patient with the run uh yeah dallas
dallas is you know
there are a different offense that we've
seen in years past mike they are
explosive and they can throw the ball as
good as we've seen them maybe since you
know tony romo and you know and his
prime and all of that but it's come back
to bite them a little bit because of the
turnovers you know and and it put them
in a tough spot yesterday amari cooper
drops a ball that goes right off his
chest intercepted uh you know then then
a little later later on in the first
half dak throws a stupid interception
and and with the way that packers were
kind of rolling that was all she wrote
even though it was kind of a nice little
comeback effort by the cowboys the
cowboys had 563 total yards most they've
ever had in a losing effort and look hey
it's good to know they can move the ball
when they're behind
but
you can't expect to dig a hole like that
if you're the cowboys because your
offense isn't built to score that many
points in the second half down 31-3
you're not built to close that gap
you're built to build a gap like that
sure not to close a gap like that so i
think you can take some encouragement
from the fact that they had 563 total
yards but not much not much because
they're three and two now and i think
the cowboys are one of those teams
that's been exposed by the fact that
they played no one the first three weeks
yeah okay it was the giants with eli
manning right it was washington yeah it
was the dolphins and now they step into
a couple of tougher games definitely
they lose to the saints they lose to the
packers so you know
maybe the cowboys are going to have to
scratch and claw for everything they get
this year yeah i don't know i don't know
i think i'm ready to say that i still
think this is one of the better teams in
the nfc and they'll find their way here
it wasn't like hey the saints we know on
the road there's always a tough
environment there that game was there to
be had to one as went as well ezekiel at
fumbling jason witten fumble and all
those issues you know the packers this
week yeah you know they let it get away
from themselves and their defense i
think is a little disappointing to this
point uh you know just as far as
yesterday goes just couldn't get off the
field couldn't stop the run game
couldn't contain rogers i didn't think
rogers would be able to make some of the
plays he made in the first half just
kind of buying time because of that
great pass rush but the cowboys i still
think are among the elite i really do
feel that way and they got the jets
coming up so that'll get them back on
the right track pop that schedule back
up of the dallas cowboys because look
they should easily beat the jets yes
then they have a huge home game against
the eagles sunday night football in just
13 days bye week after that at the
giants to kind of get their sea legs
back after a week off but then look at
that schedule yeah the vikings who you
never know with the vikings at the lions
at the patriots and then the bills
up until week 17. it's the real deal
that's murderers rope essentially for
the cowboys you're right i mean it
really is that is a really really tough
schedule with teams that have the proper
defense and talent to kind of slow
dallas down
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports